hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
immunotoxicology assay toolbox maximize
standardization
i am jennifer woods of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labruz and brought to you
by miltoni biotek
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
ermey roy global product manager for
flow cytometry reagents at milton a
biotech
ermey you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone thank you for joining us
in today's webinar
today i will discuss with you about
immunotoxicology
one of the very important segments
within drug development
in today's presentation as for
introduction i will discuss about
immunotoxicity
mainly different essay consideration
common essays and extensive validation
of those assays that are proposed by
regulatory authorities i will then focus
on experimental tools specifically flow
cytometry for essay analysis
and how we can support standardization
with our solutions
finally i will show you some of
exemplary data that are of specific
interest for immunotoxicity assessment
mainly immunophenotyping and casal
activity assay and cytokine measurement
to start with
it is no surprise to you that our
complex immune system encompassing both
innate and adaptive immune system
maintain the balance between host health
and disease
with our increasing knowledge of host
immune modulation we are now capable of
manipulating these to obtain improved
therapeutic outcomes
as consequence we see increased presence
of immunomodulatory therapies
in the field
as you all know significant number of
drug candidates fail in the clinical
trial due to safety issues drug safety
assessment therefore is a very important
battle to ensure successful development
of a therapeutic candidate
interestingly immune system was not
often considered for safety pharmacology
studies
with increasing number of
immunomodulatory drug unwanted immune
responses were also more evident
there are different immune related
adverse effect
that can be triggered by drug candidates
such as immunostimulation which results
in excessive immune response related to
for example cytokine release flu-like
reaction etc and this can
can be commonly observed
there are also um effect like
immunosuppression
which includes infectious complications
as well as virus-associated neuroplasia
and can be observed mainly in
immunocompromised patients
immune-mediated allergic reactions can
also be observed
although rather rare systematic
autoimmune responses can
can appear as adverse adverse effect
from immunomodulatory drug
with having all such adverse effects in
mind at the very end of 20th century
regulatory requirements for non-clinical
immunotoxicity evaluation of
pharmaceuticals
started to rise
currently ich s8 guidelines provide
systematic incorporation as well as the
core requirements for immunotoxicity
studies for biopharmaceuticals
which is followed by both fda as well as
emma
this guideline nicely outlines all the
detailed consideration one needs to
think about when designing
immunotoxicity studies
the initial consideration for
immunotoxicity studies depend on
standard toxicity study results
which include assessment of four key
observation
the hematology observation includes
measuring the total as well as absolute
differentiation differential
leukocyte count so one needs to check
the absolute count of the cell
cells
then there is also the aspect of
clinical chemistry where
the commonly in commonly looked
parameter is global in levels as well as
the angm ratios
and one also needs to look into the
growth growth pathology changes such as
the for lymphoid organs tissue organ
weight and as well as for measuring the
thymus and
spleen
in terms of changing the weight of this
uh also optionally and different lymph
nodes can be measured
the last parameter is this histology um
aspect and um the recommendation are
there for looking into thymus clean and
draining lymph node and
at least one of the additional lymph
node to
check the histo
histology
and properties of these
specific organs
additional immunotoxicity study
consideration comes next and the initial
consideration depends on the results um
obtained from standard toxicity studies
and to conduct additional immunotoxicity
studies several factor needs to be
considered
mainly based on the weight of evidence
as i mentioned and from the standard
toxicity studies other factors include
pharmacological properties of drug for
example of course if the drug
mode of action is an immunomodulation
there is higher chance of um observing
uh immune effect adverse immune effect
so
this can this should be considered then
the intended patient population as i
mentioned earlier immunosup immuno
patient that's suffering for
immunocompromising in immunocompromised
um disease
will
more likely show adverse more adverse
effects so such population also needs to
be considered
structural similarities with other known
immuno modulator also indicate uh also
the indication for um additional
immunotoxicity and study consideration
and moreover disposition of the drug as
well as the clinical information can
support um
the fact that additional aluminum and
toxicity studies are needed
additional immunotoxicity studies
typically consist of repeated dose
effect at least um four weeks and the
most common essay that is considered as
the first line of sa is known as t cell
dependent antibody response that is tdar
assa
and this this essay can access the
global immune function
commonly used essay here is ndklh
antibody response which is measured by
elisa typically done in rodent model
second line of essay include measuring
lymphocyte subset via immunophenotyping
although this essay is not a strict
immune function essay the result offers
valuable insight
about immune cell subset and composition
which could give specific response
if these two assets suggest specific
self cell subset independent
specific cell subs and dependent
toxicity response then further essays
are recommended to confirm those
specific response such essay includes
for example nk cell activity essay
where one checks the cytotoxicity um
yeah cytotoxicity feature of the nk cell
further on host resistance studies are
also performed which um
yeah
factors like tumor proliferation can be
monitored
further on uh some in vitro macrophage
as well as neutrophil function assays
are also suggested where one can look
into the phagocytosis um oxidative burst
as well as
phytolytic activities of these uh cell
subsets
um
last but not least um
there are also recommendations to
measure essays
for cell-mediated immunity specifically
delay type hypersensitivity reaction
all these different types of assays are
a different test model can be used for
some there are of course in vitro
studies can be performed
in many cases these are recommended to
run this essay and rodden model also
non-human primate model are considered
um sometimes depending on the drug
compound
canine models are also used
now to ensure the confidence of this
essay result extensive validation is
required and as well as recommended in
these guidelines
such as um what can affect this kind of
variation is um intel and intra essay
precision and there is also
increasing concern about variability
coming from different operator
that
indicating technician to technician
precision
as well as the accuracy and sensitivity
of the essay one is to validate
extensively
specificity of the essay is also
important
one needs to see the robustness
linearity across different time
and um
of course
even though
the studies are non-clinical at the
non-clinical stage and it bridges the
connection to clinics and some of the
assays are also suggested to
done under gmp
glp environment
um
variation in essay can result in
significant um economic impact
publication in 2015 in frost biology
reported that 50 of pre-clinical
research is irreproducible resulting in
a waste of almost
29 billion years dollar the resources of
such um the sources of such variability
is also categorized um
differently the top culprit of which is
biological reasons and reference
material which
refers to almost 63
36 percent of the year produce ability
reason
uh also followed by a study design um
and that can also affect uh ear produce
ability um
causing almost 27 percent of uh um as
the reason
and
the third
variability comes from data analysis as
well as the way it's reported 25 percent
of the reason of irreproducibly com
comes from data analysis and finally um
a correct protocol in the lab that is
followed and
results in 10 percent of
irreproducibility
now what uh one could um do to avoid all
this irreproducibility and um
utilize uh the
better tool experimental tool tools to
ensure standardization as i mentioned
before i will particularly focus on
first adventure technology for
immunotoxicity as analysis and also our
solutions for that
um
flow cytometry offers several advantages
why it could be used for immune toxicity
assay over other analysis technology
and some of them are listed here and
some of you are already aware that of
course this tool offers to a single cell
resolution and one can perform essays in
a higher throughput also obtaining
higher content
you can zoom within the sub-population
and get more in-depth data out of your
experiment um of course one can
analyze the entire population of cells
and in a higher throughput and um this
tool also allows you to multiplex as
well as um yeah it is
compared to some other available
technology it can be also easy
um
if you remember uh some of the essays
that were shown previously um
um
as an analysis of some of those essay
flow cytometry can obviously be used and
you can
as a first
essay you can think about immuno
phenotyping um however um not only
immuno phenotyping one can um
um
also perform uh
flow cytometry analysis to measure
cytotoxicity um also proliferation cell
proliferation and then um
to measure the cell counting at
subcellular level through sedimentary is
also really excellent tool um
also this advanced procedure allows you
to monitor phagocytosis and oxidative
burst so all in all um
all these different aspects can be
measured by flow cytometry
now of course this flow cytometry
analysis also comes with a lot of
variability some of which i already
mentioned earlier um that is associated
with the essay variation
um
and here
of course one of the main very variation
is coming from the donor so
[Music]
the sample that you are measuring via
this analysis tool coming obviously from
different owner and this of course is
one of the source of variability then
what type of protocol and panel design
one is considering um can vary from left
to left percent person
especially if you remember the study
also showed reason is uh one of the
important um factor which contributes to
asset variation which comes along with
the lateral consistency and specificity
variation
procytometer instrumentation also
can cause variability especially due to
operator um
handling the instrumentation and doing
different type of pipetting and so on
and finally also of course analyze this
can and reporting can vary from person
to person
um of course donor binary variability is
a very difficult aspect to tackle and uh
this is something uh one needs to
carefully consider when setting up the
essay
and and something of which we are not
able to support but at multibiotech we
offer
a lot of solutions for flow cetimetry
which can support the other aspect of
the variability for your immunotoxicity
essay
to start with um one of the important um
reasons for immunotoxicity as is
antibodies of course um
mainly for your immunophenotyping
mildew biotech through its pioneering
technology
offers recombinant antibodies since 2012
which offer the best quality
immunophenotyping results
our antibody portfolio particularly
targets the most commonly faced
challenges in the field such as the bad
antibody and low antibody quality due to
its uh
a lot lot cons inconsistency uh and
specificity also less sensitivity and
also um
you might
use antibody which are not validated for
its intended application there are also
reported challenges faced by a customer
in the field that comes from
unspecific background signal mediated by
fc receptor
and uh some of the complexity in terms
of experimental planning and our
outdated hybridoma technology
our refinity
antibodies with its um
unique uh feature of um
one isotype backbone as well as
mutated fc region
offers this
additional benefit and can
help you to tackle all these challenges
what do i mean
i would like to show you here uh one um
example data uh specifically um for n
for your nk cell analysis um
as nk cell also is important component
and can be um used for immunotoxicity
studies so here i show you two different
dataset where our recombinant antibody
was
shown to perform better so in the
left-hand picture
you can see the cd56
that is conjugated to different
fluorochrome
and the left three plot are coming from
our affinity antibody conjugated to our
conjugated traditional fitsy and dye as
well as our
brighter and better vio bright family
die and
you can clearly appreciate a very nice
clear response of this cd56 antibody
conjugated to our bio biodiverse
the right hand plot shows you an
actually a clear example of
unspecific response
here
you can see
cd56 and q2 dl1
antibody is staining in a in a sample
and
what you are expecting is that all the
cells
of nk cells
in
will be double positive and
on the right hand side you can see that
there is unspecific response which is
356 negative and um this
potential is coming from unspecific uh
binding with um
some fc receptor so um what you can see
here that in combination with our virus
of course the antibodies are giving you
enhanced brightness
as well as this mutated fc receptor of
our refined antibody allows significant
reduction of unspecific background
signals
finally uh
i want to about our antibodies i want to
highlight that we offer more than
sixteen thousand full chrome conjugated
products that are cross-sective to
different species um uh not only human
but also different rotten species canine
as well as non-human climate and
and
also their portfolio covers
all the major markers to identify
different cells upset immune checkpoint
marker for cell signaling cells
proliferation and so on and we also
provide specific list um
and detailing our antibody
correspectivity specific to different
non-human climate species which is um
where
yeah the varieties of our antibodies can
be easily selected for non-human primate
toxicity studies
nuclear biotic also offers ranges of
flow cytometer
known as maxwell analyzer family that
offers an
ultimate automation and focuses on
operator induced variability our fuel
certimeter ensures automation through
its simple use by automated startup
shutdown and some of other routing
calibration and qc measurement
also introduces operator variability
through sample labeling and processing
in an automated manner
and we also support with automated data
acquisition and analysis
within our maxcoin family we have a
special max quant
we which is known as x1x this is also
can be used for high throughput essay
and can give you result as fast as uh
analyzing 96 well played in 15 minutes
um
all our flow centimeter offers very
precise
data so all this automation does not
hamper the quality of your data and it
um ensures um
as minimal and carryover in the in the
field
that is available as well as support the
absolute cell counting which i will show
you a little and
with one slide later and
the other feature of consistent result
through on unibody optical bench and
multi instrument alignment i will also
highlight shortly
since um many of um
our
customer in the immunotoxicology field
feature um appreciate this absolute cell
counting uh performance of the max
control centimeter i would like to
highlight this um also here in this
webinar today
um in the
in this plot that is you can see right
now
now this implant shows you the cell
counting performance of 100 maxcon
device produced consequent consecutively
and how it perform in regards to its
precision of cell counting
as you can see the data shows highly
precise and reproducible cell count only
with
0.95 percent of cv
and here is another data set which shows
you um
which was generated to monitor the
linearity of the cell counting
performance and from this data set you
can see that um our um
our device demonstrate nearly perfect
linear counting over um a large dynamic
range so this could be of a high benefit
for
immunotoxicity studies where you care
for
absolute cell counting
i would like to highlight quickly
another feature of the cell analyzer
that is important for accurate
immunotoxicity studies that is
multi-instrument alignment when you
require to have your asses transfer
across department and need to ensure
performance over time our instrument and
ensures this multi instrument alignment
through
calibration and qc as well as
transferring the consistent result uh
dependent on user instrument and
location
and this is done through uh transferring
the exact settings of the instrument uh
from one instrument to
other and i would like to share with you
here um one of the interesting data set
which was generated by five different
operator who did not have flow cytometry
expertise that much and they run the
same sample in five different max one
indicated here as different numbers
and um
and these devices
underwent with this multi instrument
alignment and as you can see from this
overlay plot that all this instrument
generated exact same day and result of
the analyzes performance confirming this
accuracy of
data over instrument and operator
regarding essay analysis i would also
like to point out uh our fda compliance
software
which can be important for imminent
society studies especially under glp
environment for proper data and
documentation our mexican device
software is equipped with 21 cfr part 11
for data acquisition and analysis you
can document user management audit rail
as well as electric electronic record
very nicely and can
demonstrate this to your regulatory
authorities very um yeah um
very nice way
the um other part of the
data analysis support that i would like
to highlight is um of course um
if you think about flow data gating is
one of the problem that originates from
who is analyzing the data
this um this data set as you can see in
the screen and clearly shows that um
that with the shift of the positive
population one needs to consider how to
set the uh proper gate and um this will
obviously vary from who is analyzing the
data
to solve this problem
our uh max quantity uh file software is
equipped with a feature that we call as
express mode which is an algorithm based
analysis um cell and yeah flow cytometry
analysis tool and this is um
this is supporting automated data
analysis resulting in simplicity as well
as avoiding human error um
by
analyzing the data by different person
so thereby also enhancing the
standardization as well as
reproducibility and what is also nice
then of course it's quick and
robust analysis can be performed and can
be easily integrated into in your sop
i'll give some exemplary data in
in the end to show you how this can be
helpful for your imminent toxicity
studies
so these were all about all the product
features and how this can be
with some of the quick data but i of
course want to show how these tools can
support you with your immunotoxicity
assays and therefore i picked a few um
exemplary data set to to show you how
together all our flow analysis solution
can help you better uh to to design as
well as run your immunotoxicity studies
so the first example includes here a
basic immunophenotyping here um
human peripheral blood samples were
stained with antibody panel and here you
can see from the list that consists of
full recombinant antibodies and the
markers were chosen to discriminate
general subsets such as t cell diesel
and castle and more
and using our quant and as well as this
available immunophenotyping express mode
um this is a clear
exemplary data that you can expect by
using this automated data analysis where
cells are gated automatically based on
their
yeah subsets and um
this is
defined based on the scatter plot as
well as the
subset definition based on the specific
marker expression
you can also expect to see a
accompanying data table and which you
see on the right hand in the bottom and
that elucidate further details on the
cell subset percentage as well as the
absolute it offers you the absolute cell
count uh features so
if you use
our antibody panel and then use this in
combination with express mode and
next one you will be able to analyze the
large
samples sample subset much more
automated manner and you will be able to
get this data set in a more concise and
easy way
and can also avoid operator dependent
variability
next i want to highlight you uh also
that immuno phenotyping within imminent
office studies of course can span over
not only general immuno phenotyping but
also more
subset specific phenotyping
and one of the problem that um
comes with the variability that um
information source can be variable and
this can complicate the setup of the
panel particularly to decide what type
of markers to choose which antibody fuel
combination will work
how to set up gating etc
and we understand this problem in the
field and to address this problem we
started to generate an antibody panel
collection
and this is known as our melting biotic
tested panel where currently we have
nearly 40 antibody panel covering
different cell subsets
these panels are established and tested
by our internal rnd expert as well as
kindly provide the data by our customers
and here i just wanted to show you what
kind of data you can expect and
therefore i showed you an example of a
mouse using phil and neutrophil
xenotyping panel that we have
where you can see the panel composition
so um
the top
top right um
box shows you this antibody panel which
includes what marker was used which
clone in
was behind this marker as well as the
floor combination and what was the
purpose to use this marker
and then you can expect to see how to
set up a gate define certain cell subset
and of course it is uh coming together
with a detailed protocol of staining
protocol to um so that you can just
directly uh copy this protocol and uh we
hope that with this this panel
collection which we are also
continuously growing this can support
the scientific community with their
further studies
the next example that i want to
highlight is a nk cell activity essay
this particular essay was performed in
our rnd
and the essay setup was shown as you can
see it here in the graphical
illustration
first nk cells were isolated from
peripheral blood via two different
method in both using our pioneering
magnetic beam based cell isolation
method
one method included untrust isolation of
nk cells using cd56 micro bead
and isolated nk cells um were then
cultured with different target cell
with different ratio and side toxicity
was measured um using flow cytometry um
using propidium iodide labeling
and
of course the other method was isolating
the nk cells using a straightforward
method
and
the next essay followed the same
principle
here you can see the data so the left
hand uh
the flow cytometry plot here shows you
the different um
that um different
isolation method resulted in slight
difference
on isolated subset the straight from
method resulted in enrichment of cd3
positive expressing inkt cells
which were missing in the untouched
method
cells from different isolation method
also resulted in slight difference in
the cytotoxicity result in both those
dependent direct healing effect here on
this middle plot down in the middle plot
as well as on the antibody mediated
killing effect
so you can expect um
also um as i mentioned earlier you can
also use flow cytometry to just directly
measure this um cytotoxicity in
at a single cell level so this is
basically highlights this feature in in
such a nk cell activity
measurement essay
for the last example of cytokine
measurement
we used our base method to measure
multiple secreted cytokines quant
quantitatively to those who are not
familiar with how this method works here
is a quick outline
of the principle on the left hand side
outline so basically secreted cytokines
are captured by fruits and label beads
coated with capture antibody
and then you um
you will stain it with anti
ng cytokine antibody and you you can
also use a detection antibody and
labeled with the fluoro uh
fluorochrome and then all these
different bead population that are
coated with different
detection region can be separated and
therefore multiplexed
and
this feature comes in combination with
also the express mode that i highlighted
before so you can simply use our maxplex
reagents and then use the express mode
analysis tool together with our next one
and this allows you use uh to generate a
very nice automated um
essay analysis which can be of course
complicated when one needs to do all
this gating manually so the middle plot
here shows how
this um analyze this tool helps to
generate a standard curve
for the cytokine for different for
different cytokine in the essay and the
last plot on the right hand side shows
um
an exemplary
data that is generated with the express
mode to calculate the cytokine
concentration of each analyte of the
unknown sample
now this technology was applied to this
um
for the cytokine measurement in a mixed
lymphocyte reaction essay and this data
was kindly provided by our customer
and and uh essay was done in a mouse
model
so the acid setup looks like this where
um
splenocytes uh so cd
c3 positive t cells were isolated from
splenocyte
and then they were co-cultured with uh
also splenocyte and from a t-cell
depleted mouse
and then um after this co-culture
experiment of course some um
interesting compound were added to
monitor how it changes the cytokine
profile and and this cytokine
measurement was done using our next
black skip
in a max quant using the express mode
and here is the list of cytokine that
were measured together in a multi
multiplex
manner i'm just showing you all the data
that customer provided where they found
it interesting in in terms of a
different compound so they basically um
co-cultured with different concentration
of their compound of interest
and observed those dependent cytokine
response specifically in gmcc interferon
gamma and i have 17
and um
of course um as i mentioned with this
automated tool you can expect to see
such those dependent cytokine response
in a rather automated manner
with this i come to my last slide of the
presentation here
i would like to highlight the
summary that uh of course
standardization of assay is very
important and specifically um
also immunotoxicity studies and uh
optimized tool can be used to
better support uh the
asset standardization
and of course at milton project we help
you to improve these uh assets and
enhance the standardization by offering
our
recommended antibody portfolio that is
um
across different species and also highly
reproducible um
in terms of giving you immunophenotyping
data
we also showed you how you could use our
automated flow cytometer tool to reduce
operator dependent variability and also
obtain high quality data including
accurate and absolute cell counting
as i mentioned also it is
if you are performing your
immunotoxicity essays under glp
environment
our fda compliance software can help you
there and um
extra small solutions could offer an
operator independent um essay analysis
and
enhance there by the standardization
finally uh we we really believe that our
tested panel that i showed you earlier
this collection of panel can support um
support you to establish your panel
thereby saving your time required to
extensively validate your immuno
phenotyping panel if you want to of
course see more and learn more what
solutions we provide you
can go visit our website or can
contact us also
directly
with this uh i would like to thank you
all for listening to to me and i hope uh
some of this information was helpful to
you if you have any question i would be
very happy to answer them and otherwise
of course um you can get back to me
later and thank you and have
i wish you everyone a nice day
thank you ermey for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what are the differences with untouched
versus straight from protocol of nk cell
isolation
thanks
thanks for the question um
of course i had to go quite fast uh with
this step
um
i think it's um it's a really good
question to
so we have of course um our pioneering
technology using magnetic beat to
isolate
certain subset of interest
and in this particular um experiment
they have used two different methods
one was
yeah basically targeting um
to isolate the nk cell by specific
marker like like cd56 uh which was
straight from and um
for the untouched method there were
negative markers used where um
to not to touch the um
nk cell as it is so you basically get
out of all the unwanted uh cell subset
and um of course if you pick a specific
marker cd56 which is also expressed by
some other subset therefore you you get
to see this cd56 expressing uh inkt cell
subpopulation within the uh within the
straight from uh isolation protocol and
yeah depending on what is your
expectation um
to to see in terms of cytotoxicity
performance of of the of the cell subset
um you can
yeah go ahead with uh with the
any of this method
should yeah work fine
that was
oh i'm sorry
i just wanted to say i hope that was
clear i mean otherwise if there is any
question for detailed protocol you can
of course write i mean i'm not expert in
many of uh some of these
essays because it was done by our r d
counterpart but of course i would be
happy to yeah
provide
more detailed information if that is
requested
thank you army let's see our next
question here what type of documentation
is offered with recombinant antibodies
and what kind of validation is done to
check performance
um
thanks for the question so um so our
recommended antibodies we offer as a
research use
so researchers only product and there um
we offer this
standard documentation which is
certificate of analysis and
if you purchase our antibody it's very
easy you can go to the website and
download this certificate of analyze
this we also offer
to customer whose interest to get more
yeah requires advanced document and
certain type of specific information in
regards to concentration of the product
and so on
um this can also
be offered this can also be handed out
to customer upon request
um in terms of validation of course we
have state of the art validation that
um yeah follows the production as well
as the quality control of the product
in specific to a recombinant antibody we
also perform
a lot of extended validation to kind of
ensure the the specificity of the
antibody and in terms of what target
they are recognizing and via
epidural
epidural blocking experiment and we also
support extended validation data with
some of our antibodies with the knockout
cell line
and um also we compare one to one
performance of our antibodies so there
are a lot of um yeah validation data
available for uh many of our product
line if you're interested you can also
of course find them in the product page
thank you army we have one more question
here how are the gates set with express
mode
that's a that's a good question um
i guess
our
software specialist would be the best
person to
to explain really nice uh how this
really nice function works in the
software so
basically it's it works
with with algorithm and
they
they analyze more than 300
samples for specific um express mode for
example the one i showed for
immunophenotyping
and they measure more than 300 uh sample
subset and uh try to um
basically with um yeah
advanced algorithm to uh try to see
where the population should lie within
um
certain uh market distribution and so
based on that um
the gate is basically defined and of
course um
to define the subset um the gating is
taken
from what is typically used in the field
yeah
great thank you army
do you have any final comments for our
audience before we go
um so of course as i mentioned
it was a presentation in nutshell and if
you are interested to learn further
especially the application example
that was shown um due to time limitation
of course i did not go too much into
detail there are also much more
application data available um
there are yeah tested and also validated
some of them are by our r d colleague if
you are interested please reach out and
um also if you're interested for the
presentation um the the slide deck
i would be happy to yeah
send it via email
well thank you again dr ermey roy for
your time today and for your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor miltoni biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
thank you
thank you